[Music]  Charlize Theron's touched down in Austin  Texas for the South by Southwest  festival to promote her upcoming spy  thriller atomic blonde  in the movie Charlize shares steamy  scenes with sofia boutella she's a  dancer I'm a dancer so we're a little  bit like you know dancers are like what  being naked is nothing so you made  contact with the French operative  obviously the Oscar winner is kicking  ass and taking names in the film out  July 28 but admits that's just half the  entry what is it about these characters  that you love portraying so much I don't  know I think they're all very vulnerable  to I think great strengths comes from  women who can be vulnerable and look at  their weaknesses and kind of find their  strengths from that you look like you  need saving she's a killer  [Music]